all of Oslo as usual makes a beautiful
frame around the turn the main hall is
decorated with flowers in strong clear
colors orchids carnations lilies
gerberas dialects and priests and the
ropes
the case winners are the last ones to
arrive and they're just about now
they're arriving at the hall
the three representatives of the EU are
to receive the Peace Prize arriving now
at the whole Herman Van Rompuy President
of the European Council for silymarin
but also president of the you opposition
and president and director of the bell
Institute gave the stuff
every year the Nobel diploma to be given
to the winners is created by a Norwegian
artist this year the artist is get
tingling
most of the invited guests are already
in their places and waiting for the
processions of the heads of state prize
winners and the royal family on the left
side of the hall are representatives of
official Norway among them are the
president of Parliament Dalton Anderson
Prime Minister Jens Stoltenberg and his
wife and High Court research to the show
also present are several cabinet
ministers
Foreign Minister has been but either
here
I grew harem Brinton with former Prime
Minister of Norway and beside her total
stole by former cabinet member and
father of Norwegian Prime Minister today
and now for trumpeters from his majesty
the Kingsguard will be playing a fanfare
as the Prime Minister tusk opponent here
are the president of Hungary Prime
Minister of France Francois or loud
and so the royal family is arriving at
the City Hall
they are always present at this event
King Hiram and Queen Sonja who are now
welcomed by too lenient and yet Linda
stop
so the foreign heads of state have found
their places in the hall and we're
waiting for the precision of the theory
sensitives who are to receive the peace
price of today
everybody in the building for the
[Music]
Parliament the three recipients have a
tight schedule and have hectic hours
during their short stay in the low
eighteen capital they have already been
received at the royal palace this
morning by the king and queen
wealthy recipients was Emily when I left
the trumpeters are all set to play
parade march in honor of the king who
and his family will arrive very soon
the Norwegian Prime Minister has already
today had a meeting here at the city
hall with German Chancellor Angela
[Music]
and so the royal family in Sanya Crown
Prince hopeful and prompt assessment
audit they're always present at this
Nobel Peace Prize event and now when the
Royals are in their places they
certainly will start and it will start
with music now reach the artists and
your him sing on the violin and horror
games accompanying on the piano with
bewitched music first Norwegian dance
number one by Johann Halverson and then
boots Lisa or a good song by little
bitch Eddie's yes
[Music]
[Applause]
and now the leader of the week a Nobel
Committee Toby Raglan will give his
presentation speech
you know maturities royal highnesses
heads of state and governments
excellencies ladies and gentlemen dear
presidents of the Maine EU institutions
the Nobel laureate welcome to Oslo to
this beautiful city hall and thank you
for bringing so many heads of state and
governments along with you so that we
together by handing over the Nobel Peace
Prize can celebrate the fact that Europe
that was a continent of peace over war
has become a continent of peace and that
we give the message to Europe that this
must not be taken forgiven we have to
struggle for it every day
congratulations for the big prize
[Applause]
at the time when Europe is undergoing
great difficulties the Norwegian Nobel
Committee has sought to call to mind
what the European Union means for peace
in Europe after the two world wars in
the last century the world had to turn
away from nationalism and move in the
direction of international cooperation
the United Nations were formed the
Universal Declaration of Human Rights
was adopted for Europe where both world
wars had broken out the new
internationalism had to be a binding
commitment it had to be built on
enforceable principles of human rights
democracy and the rule of law and on
Economic Cooperation aimed at making the
countries equal partners in the European
market place by these means the
countries would be bound together so as
to make new worlds impossible the Coal
and Steel community of 1951 marked the
start of a process of reconciliation
which has continued right to the present
day beginning in Western Europe the
process continued across the east-west
divide when the Berlin Wall fell and has
currently reached the Balkans where
there were bloody Wars less than 15 to
20 years ago the EU has constantly been
a central driving force throughout these
processes of reconciliation the EU has
in fact helped to bring about balls
the fraternity between Nations and the
promotion of peace congress's of which
Alfred Nobel wrote in his will
the Nobel Peace Prize is therefore both
deserved and necessary and we all offer
our congratulations
in light of the financial crisis that is
affecting so many innocent people we can
see that the political framework in
which a union is rooted is more
important than ever we must stand
together we have collective
responsibility without this European
cooperation the result might easily have
been new protectionism new nationalism
with the risk that the ground gained
would be lost and we know from the
interwar years that this is what can
happen when ordinary people pay the
bills for a financial crisis triggered
by others that is solution now as then
is not for the countries to act on their
own at the expense of others nor to
blame Brunell able minorities that would
lead us into yesterday's stop Europe
needs to move forward safeguard what has
happened and what we have gained and
improve what has been created enabling
us to solve the problems threatening the
European Community today this is the
only way to get out of the problems
created by the financial crisis to
everyone's benefit in 1926 the Norwegian
Nobel Committee awarded the Peace Prize
to the foreign ministers of France and
Germany arrested
Briona Gustav tradesmen and the
following year to fight in and Warsaw
and would-be quitter
all for their efforts to advance
franco-german reconciliation in the
1930s the reconciliation degenerated as
we all know into conflict and war after
the Second World War the reconciliation
between Germany and France
laid the very foundations for European
integration the two countries had waged
three wars in the space of 70 years in
the franco-prussian war in 1870 to 71
and then the first and the second world
wars in the first years after 1945 it
was very tempting to contain God to
continue along the same track
emphasizing revenge and conflict then on
the 9th of May 1915 the French Foreign
Minister Robert Sherman present the
plans for a Coal and Steel community and
the government in Paris and one decided
to set the history on a completely
different course by placing the
production of coal and steel under
adjoined authority the principal
elements of armaments production we're
to form the beams for the structure of
peace economic cooperation with from
then on prevent divorce and conflicts in
Europe as Schumann put it in his 9th of
May speech the Solidarity in production
thus established will make it plain that
any war between France and Germany
becomes not merely unthinkable but
materially impossible the reconciliation
between Germany and France is probably
the most dramatic example in history to
show that war and conflict can be turned
solve rapidly into peace and cooperation
and ladies and gentlemen the person's
here today
Oh German Chancellor Angela Merkel and
French president Francois Hollande make
this day very particular symbolic for
all of us
[Applause]
the next step after the Coal and Steel
community was a signing of the Treaty of
Rome on the 25th of March 1957 the Four
Freedoms were now established borders
were to be opened and not and the whole
economy not just the coal and steel
industry was to be woven into a whole
the six heads of government of Germany
France Italy the Netherlands Belgium and
Luxembourg wrote that they was thus
pooling the resources to preserve and
strengthen peace and liberty and calling
upon the other peoples of Europe to
share their ideal to join in their
efforts in 1973 Great Britain Ireland
and Denmark decided to respond to this
call Greece joined the 1981 and Spain
and Portugal in 1986 members of the EEC
and later the European Union was the
right for all European countries as it
was written whose system of government
is founded on the principle of democracy
and who accept the conditions for
membership membership consolidated
democracy in these countries not least
through the generous support schemes
from which Greece Portugal and Spain
were able to benefit the next step
forward came when the Berlin Wall fell
in the course of a miraculous half year
in 1981 89 opportunities open up for the
neutral countries Sweden Finland and
Austria to become members but the new
democracies too wish to become part of
the West militarily economically and
culturally in that connection the
membership of the European Union was as
self-evident objective and amines
enabling the transition to democracy to
be made as painlessly as possible if
they were left to themselves nobody
could be certain how things would turn
out because history has taught us that
freedom comes at a price
the difference is very marked between
what happened after the fall of the
Berlin Wall and what is now happening in
the Arab world the Eastern European
countries were quickly able to
participate in a European community of
shared values join in a large market and
benefit from economic support the new
democracies in the vicinity of Europe
have no such free safe haven to make for
the transition to democracy looks like
being long and painful and has already
triggered war and conflict in Europe
however the division between East and
West was broken down more quickly than
anyone could have anticipated democracy
has been strengthened in a region the
Democratic traditions were very limited
the many disputes of ethnicity and
nationality
that had so troubled the region have
largely been settled Michael Gorbachev
created the external conditions for the
emancipation of Eastern Europe and
national leaders headed by elite valensa
took the necessary local initiatives
balls bonanza and gorbachev received
their well-deserved Peace Prizes now it
is the EU s turn events during the month
it is absolutely clear that events
during the months and years following
the fall of the Berlin Wall
may have amounted to the greatest act of
solidarity ever on the European
continent and this collective effort
could not have come about without the
political Anakim economic right way of
the European Union behind it and on this
very day we must also pay tribute to the
Federal Republic of Germany and the
Chancellor Helmut Kohl for assuming
responsibility and accepting the
enormous costs on behalf of the
inhabitants of the Federal Republic when
East Germany was included practically
overnight in a united Germany it has
served us all thank you very much
not everything was settled yet however
with the fall of communism and all
problem returned the Balkans
Tito's authoritarian rule had kept a lid
on the many ethnic conflicts and when
that lid was lifted violent conflicts
blazed up again five Wars very in fact
fought in a spot in the space of a few
years and again aside we will never
forget surreal in its own where eight
thousand Muslims were massacred in a
single day now however the European
Union is seeking to lay the foundations
for peace also in the Balkans terenia
joined the EU in 2004 Croatia will
become a member next year Montenegro has
open membership negotiations and Serbia
and the Former Yugoslav Republic of
Macedonia have been given candidate
status the Balkans where and are a
complicated region and resolve conflicts
remain surface dimension that the status
of Kosovo is still not finally settled
Bosnia Herzegovina is a state that
hardly functions owing to the veto the
three population groups have become
entitled to exercise against each other
several hundred thousand people that do
not belong to these groups are not
enjoying full democratic rights the
paramount solution is to extend the
process of integration that has applied
in the rest of Europe so that borders
become less absolute which population
group one belongs to no longer
determines ones security the European
Union must accordingly plenum play a
main part here
- to bring about a real peace
for several decades Turkey and the
European Union have been discussing the
relation to each other after the new
government headed by the ark party there
will not clear parliamentary majority
the aim of EU membership has provided a
guideline for the process of reform in
Turkey there can be no doubt that this
has contributed to strengthening the
development of democracy there and this
benefits Europe but success in this
respect is also very important for the
Middle East the development there and
therefore also for world peace and I
would like to make an important point in
that disrespect regarding Nobel Peace
Prize namely that the Norwegian Nobel
Committee has time and again presented
the Peace Prize to champ champions of
Human Rights now the price is going to
an organization of which one cannot
become a member without first having
adapted their dedication to the
Universal Declaration of Human Rights
and the European Convention on Human
Rights but human rights our church are
not enough we can see this now that
country of the country is coming
undergoing serious social unrest because
misplaced policies corruption tax
evasion have led the money being poured
into gaping black holes
this leads understandably to protests
demonstrations are part of our democracy
but the task of politics is to transform
the protesters and the protest into
concrete political action the very out
of the difficulties is not to
and the European institutions we need to
maintain solidarity across borders as
the Union is doing by canceling debts
and adopting all the concrete support
measures and by formulating the
framework for a finance industry on
which we all depend and faithful
servants must be removed these are
preconditions for the continuing belief
of the European masses in the
compromises and moderation which Union
is now demanding of them your Majesties
the Royal Highnesses heads of state and
governments presidents of the European
Union
ladies and gentlemen John Mooney said
that nothing can be achieved without
human beings but nothing becomes
permanent
without institutions we are not gathered
here in the belief that the European
Union is perfect we are gathered in the
belief that here in Europe we must solve
the other problems together for that
purpose we need institutions that can
make the necessary compromises we need
institutions to ensure that both nation
states and individuals exercise
self-control and moderation in a world
with so many dangers compromise
self-control and moderation are the
principle needs of 21st century and that
is why we need institutions to achieve
exactly that and rule of law human
rights and democracy 18 million people
soldiers
had to pay the price bid their own lives
for the opposite the exercise of
extremism in Europe so together we must
ensure that they do not lose what we
have built on the ruins of the two world
wars what this continent has achieved is
truly fantastic from being a continent
of war to becoming a continent of peace
in this process the European Union has
figured most prominently it therefore
deserves the Nobel Peace Prize
so dear noble low-rate dear old friends
some of the frescoes on the walls here
in the oslo city hall or inspired by
Ambrogio Lorenzetti s frescoes from the
1300 in the siena
town hall named allegory of the effects
of good government the fresco solves
this fresco in siena shows a living
medieval town with the gates in the wall
invitingly wide open two-spirited people
bringing the harvest in from protrude
pills but Lawrence setting painted
another picture which is also in Siena
allegory of the effects of bad
government it serves Siena in chaos
closed and ravaged by the plague
destroyed by a struggle for power and
world the two pictures were meant to
remind us that it is up to ourselves
whether or not we are to live in a very
ordered circumstances so may good
government win in Europe we are bound
together living together vivre ensemble
so Simon Lebon convivencia belittle
Islamic read the mr. Lieberman
congratulations to Europe in the in the
end we decided to live together and may
good government continue to prevail it
is up to us
congratulations to all Europeans
posting to the young ones presentation
speech there will be more music
[Applause]
now why they put the geese for musical
okay Estrada who is said to have
rejuvenated Portuguese folk music sorry
my English I must say little few words
and the next song it's a little fat oh
and we dedicate that to Europe
it calls in you there is something
Ashera me up and it's to a new Europe
and I think when the north and the south
of Europe meet each other know each
other they can fall in love and then
everything starts a new event a venture
so it's like that idea
Brendon kalmyk a much palabras que no
Lima I'm TIA pocket weasel
Brandon a pocket quiz immense sacrifice
even Arash so mean wasn't your friend
notion teaser Samina
it's an EVA masa we have on Todd
motion Filomena if any more massive on
top no more bite my Raja ends yeah so
does my scooter
but what yeah okay King funny too much
for Tokyo person my scooter
the qualia opening fight my Sparta do
care for survival is she even bother
Masood Uzi my yard you were who you he
ever saw Ella
I come here to come so L little Sparta
music course though yeah so city home
the winners of this year's Nobel Peace
Prize will now be called to the rostrum
to receive their medals and diplomas
your Majesties your Royal Highnesses had
so state and governments ladies and
gentlemen I call upon present Herman Van
Rompuy present Bruce a Manuel Barroso
and Martin Schulz president of European
Parliament all three of them
representing the three main European
Union institutions to come forward to
receive the diploma and the medal the
Nobel Peace Prize for 2012
okay mr. headland pilgrim boy or similar
way but also and Martin shoes
always to get their heat to show their
respect for musicals on this year's
Nobel Peace Prize the European video
[Applause]
- all day you leaders will now give
their Nobel lectures heads of state and
Heads of Government excellencies ladies
and gentlemen I now call upon present
Herman Van Rompuy and President Barroso
the representatives of European Union to
give the nobel lecture for 2012 they
will present one speech but two chapters
[Applause]
your Majesties your Royal Highnesses
heads of state and government members of
the Norwegian Nobel Committee
excellencies ladies and gentlemen it is
with humility and gratitude that we
stand here together to receive this
award on behalf of the European Union at
a time of uncertainty this day reminds
people across Europe in the world of the
union's
fundamental purpose to further the
fraternity between European nations now
and in the future it is our work today
it has been the work of generations
before us and it will be the work of
generations after us here in Oslo I want
to pay homage to all the Europeans who
dreamt of a continent at peace with
itself and to all those who day by day
make this dream a reality this award
belongs to them
war is as old as Europe our continent
bears the scars of Spears and sorts of
cannons and guns of trenches and tanks
and more the tragedy of it all resonates
in the worlds of Herodotus 25 centuries
ago in peace sense bury their fathers in
war feathers
bury their sons yet after two terrible
Wars and gallop the continent and the
world with it finally lasting peace came
to Europe in those gray days its cities
were in ruins the hearts of many still
simmering with mourning and resentment
how difficult he then seemed as his son
Churchill said to regain the simple joys
and hopes that make life worth living as
a child born in Belgium just after the
war I heard the stories firsthand
my grandmother spoke about the Great War
and in 1940 my father then seventeen had
to dig his own grave he got away
otherwise I would not be here today
ladies and gentlemen what a ball bat it
was for Europe's founders to say yes yes
we can
well yes we can break this endless cycle
of virus we can stop the logic of
vengeance we can build a brighter future
together what power of imagination
excellencies ladies and gentlemen of
course peace might have come to Europe
without the Union maybe we will never
know but it would never have been of the
same quality a lasting peace not a
frosty ceasefire and to me what makes it
so special is reconciliation in politics
as in life reconciliation is the most
difficult thing
it goes beyond forgiving and forgetting
or simply turning the page to think of
what France and Germany had gone through
and then take this step signing a treaty
of friendship each time I hear these
words front shaft I'm ETA I am moved
there are private words not for treaties
between nations but the will not to let
let this history repeat itself
to do something radically new and that
was so strong that new words had to be
found for people Europe was a promise
Europe equaled hope when Konrad Adenauer
came to Paris to conclude the coal and
steel treaty in 1951 one evening he
found a gift waiting at his hotel it was
a war medal in quoi de guerre that had
belonged to a French soldier and his
daughter a young student had left it
with a little note for the Chancellor as
a gesture of reconciliation and of hope
I can see
I can see many other stirring images
before me leaders of the six states
assembled to open a new future in Rome
Cheeta Eterna willebrandt kneeling down
in Warsaw the Dockers of dance the gates
of the shipyards matar and coal hand in
hand two million people linking Tallinn
to Riga to Vilnius in a human chain in
1989 and these moments these moments
healed Europe
but symbolic gestures alone cannot
cement peace this is where the European
Union's secret weapon comes into play an
unrivaled way of binding our interest so
tightly that war becomes materially
impossible to constant negotiations on
ever more topics between evermore
countries and it's the golden rule of
Romani mere force a despot able to dine
table que sera Shawn Tabata better fight
around the table than on a battlefield
if you had to explain it to Alfred Nobel
I would say not just a peace Congress a
perpetual peace Congress admittedly some
aspects can be puzzling and not only to
outsiders
ministers from landlocked countries
passionately discussing fish quota euro
parliamentarians from Scandinavia
debating the price of olive oil the
Union has perfected the art of
compromise no drama
no drama or victory or defeat but
ensuring all countries emerged
victorious from talks and for this
boring politics is only a small price to
pay
ladies and gentlemen it works
peace is now self-evident war has become
inconceivable yet inconceivable does not
mean impossible and that is why we are
gathered here today Europe must keep its
promise of peace I believe this is still
our union's ultimate purpose but Europe
can no longer rely on this promise alone
to inspire citizens in a way it's a good
thing war memories are fading even if
not yet everywhere Soviet rule over
Eastern Europe and it just two decades
ago and horrendous massacres took place
in the Balkans shortly after the
children born at the time of Sabine Itza
would only turn 18 next year but they
already have little brothers and sisters
born after that war the first real
post-war generation of Europe and this
this must remain so
presidents prime ministers excellencies
so where there was war there is no peace
but another historic task now lies ahead
of us keeping peace where there is peace
after all history is not a novel a book
we can close after a happy ending we
remain fully responsible for what is yet
to come ladies and gentlemen this
couldn't be more clear than it is today
when we are hit by the worst economic
crisis in two generations causing great
hardship among our people and putting
the political bonds of our Union to the
test parents struggling to meet to make
ends meet workers recently laid off
students who fear that however hard they
try they won't get their first job when
they think about Europe peace is not the
first thing that comes to mind when
prosperity and employment the bedrock of
our societies appear Tretton it is
natural to see a hardening of hearts the
narrowing of interest even the return of
long-forgotten fault lines and
stereotypes for some not only joint
decisions but the very fact of deciding
jointly may come into doubt and why we
must keep a sense of proportion even
such tensions don't take us back to the
darkness of the past the test
Europe is currently facing is real if I
can borrow the words of Abraham Lincoln
at the time of another continental test
what's being assessed today is whether
that union or any union so conceived and
so dedicated can long endure
ladies and gentlemen we answer we are
deeds confident we will succeed we are
working very hard to overcome the
difficulties to restore growth and jobs
there is of course sheer necessity but
there is more that guides us there will
to remain masters of our own destiny a
sense of togetherness and in a way
speaking to us from the centuries the
idea of Europa itself
the presence of so many European leaders
here today underlines a common
conviction that we will come out of this
together together and stronger strong
enough in the world to defend our
interests and promote our values we all
work to leave a better Europe for the
children of today and those of tomorrow
so that later
others might earn and judge that
generation ours preserved the promise of
Europe and today use is already living
in a new world for them Europe is a
daily reality not a constraint of being
in the same boat no the richness of
being able to freely share and change to
share a continent experiences a future
excellencies ladies and gentlemen our
continent risen from the ashes after
1945 and United in 1989 as a great
capacity to reinvent itself it will also
be for the next generation to take this
common adventure further
I hope they will seize this
responsibility with pride and that they
will be able to say as we hear today ich
bin ein repair
yes we share d'etre pea
I'm proud to be European
collection the perspective the
irritation
the lecture the president of the EU
Commission who say one wing
[Applause]
your Majesties excellencies ladies and
gentlemen peace is not mere absence of
war it is a virtual Road Spinoza pax any
non belly probe a CEO said via touch s
and he added it is a state of mind a
disposition for benevolence confidence
justice indeed there can only be true
peace if people are confident at peace
with our political system we assure that
their basic rights are respected
European Union is not only about peace
among nations it incarnates as a
political project that particular state
of mind that Spinoza was referring to it
embodies as a community of values this
vision of freedom and justice I remember
vividly in 1974 being in the mass of
people descending the streets in my
native Lisbon in Portugal celebrating
the democratic revolution and freedom
this same feeling of joy was experienced
by the same generation in Spain and
Greece it was felt later in Central and
Eastern Europe and in the Baltic States
when they regained their independence
several generations of Europeans have
shown again and again that their choice
for Europe was also a choice for freedom
I will never forget Rostropovich playing
back at the Fallen wall in Berlin and
this image reminds the world that it was
the quest for freedom and democracy that
tore down the old divisions and made
possible the unification of the
continent joining European Union was
essential for the consolidation of
democracy in our country
because it places the person and human
dignity
at its heart because it gives advice to
diversity while creating unity and so
after unification Europe was able to
breathe with both its lungs as said by
Carol vitala European has become our
common house the own land of our
homelands as described by vclav havel
our union is more than an association of
states it is a new legal order which is
not based on the balance of power
between nations but on the free consent
of states to share sovereignty from
pooling : still to abolishing internal
borders from six countries to soon 28
with Croatia joining the family this has
been a remarkable European journey which
is leading us to an ever closer Union
and today one of the most visible
symbols of our unity is in everyone's
hands it is zero the currency of our
European Union we will stand by it
your excellencies ladies and gentlemen
this cannot rest only on the goodwill of
man it needs to be grounded on a body of
laws on common interests and on a deeper
sense of a community of destiny the
genius of the founding fathers was
precisely in understanding that to
guarantee peace in the 20th century
nations needed to think beyond the
nation-state as volta al stein the first
president of nutrient commission said
the system they are national startin
have been visited stand test that
transition dismissed the standard the
system of sovereign nation-states has
failed the most important test of the
20th century yet through two world wars
it has proved itself unable to preserve
peace the uniqueness of the European
project is to have combined the
legitimacy of democratic states with the
legitimacy of supranational institutions
European Commission the European Court
of Justice supranational institutions
that protect the general European
interest defend European common good and
embody the community of destiny and
alongside European Council where the
governments are represented we have over
the years developed a unique
transnational democracy symbolized by
the directly elected European Parliament
our quest for European unity is not a
perfect work of art it is working
progress that demands constant and
diligent standing it is not an end in
itself but a means to higher ends in
many ways it attests to the quest for a
cosmopolitan order in which one person's
gain does not need to be another
person's pain in which abiding by common
norms serves universal values that is
why
despite its imperfections European Union
can be and indeed is a powerful
inspiration for many around the world
because the challenges faced from one
region to the other may differ in scale
but they do not differ in nature we all
share the same planet perfectly
organized crime terrorism climate change
these are problems that do not respect
national borders we share the same
aspirations and universal values these
are progressively taking root in a
growing number of countries all over the
world we share the headed Qibla Ummah
the irreducible innateness of the human
being
beyond domination beyond our continent
we are all part of one mankind Germany
and his memoir with these words Lina
chemin de pasin SOP Ricardo who proves
residually problem the prison in a
community and men making it up
rarely formed organization demanded the
demand the sovereign nations of the past
can no longer solve the problems of the
present and the community itself is only
a stage on the way to the organized
world of the future this Federalist and
cosmopolitan vision is one of the most
important contributions that your pinion
can bring to a global order in the
making
your excellencies ladies and gentlemen
the concrete engagement of the European
Union in the world is deeply marked by
our continents tragic experience of
extreme national wars and absolute evil
of the Shoah
it is inspired by our desire to avoid
the same mistakes being made again that
is the foundation of our multilateral
approach for a globalization based on
the twin principles of global solidarity
and global responsibility that is what
inspires our engagement with our
neighboring countries and international
partners from the Middle East to Asia
from Africa to the Americas it defines
our stance against the death penalty and
our support for international justice
embodied by the International Court of
Justice and the International Criminal
Court it drives our leadership in the
fight against climate change and for
food and energy security it underpins
our policies on disarmament and against
nuclear proliferation and as a continent
that went from devastation to become one
of the world's strongest economies with
the most progressive social systems
being the world's largest age donor we
have a special responsibility to
millions of people in need in the 21st
century it is simply unacceptable to see
parents powerless as their babies dying
of lack of basic medical care mother's
compelled to work all day in the hope of
getting food or clean water and boys and
girls deprived of their childhood
because they are forced to become adults
ahead of time as a community of nations
that has overcome war and fought
totalitarianism we will always stand by
those who are in pursuit of peace and
human dignity and let me say from here
today the current situation in Syria is
a stain on the world's conscience
an international community has a moral
duty to address it
and as today marks the international
human rights day more than any other day
our thoughts go to the human rights
defenders all over the world who put
their lives at risk to defend the values
we cherish and no prison wall can
silence their voice we hear them in this
room today
we also remember that last year on this
very podium three women were honored for
their nonviolent struggle for the safety
of women and for women's rights as a
union built on the founding value of
equality between women and men enshrined
in the Treaty of Rome in 1957 we are
committed to protecting women's rights
all over the world and supporting
women's empowerment
and we cherish the fundamental rights of
those who are the most vulnerable and
all the future in their hands the
children of this world as as a
successful example of peaceful
reconciliation based on economic
integration we contribute to developing
new forms of cooperation built on
exchange of ideas innovation and
research science and culture are at the
very core of the European openness they
enrich us as individuals and they create
bonds Beyond Borders your Majesties your
Royal Highnesses heads of state and
government members of Norwegian Nobel
Committee excellencies ladies and
gentlemen ambled and grateful for the
award of the Nobel Peace Prize
there is no better place to share our
vision than here in Norway a country
which has been giving so much to the
cause of global peace the pacification
of Europe was at the heart of Alfred
Nobel's concerns in an early version of
his will he even equated it to
international peace and these echoes the
very first words of the Schumann
declaration the founding document of the
European Union lack payment young world
peace itself cannot be safeguarded
without the making of creative efforts
proportionate to the dangers which
threaten it and my message today is you
can count on our creative efforts to
fight for lasting peace freedom and
justice in Europe and in the world over
the past 60 years the European project
has shown that it is possible for
peoples and nations to come together
across borders that it is possible to
overcome the differences
between them and us and here today our
hope our commitment is that with all
women and men of goodwill the opinion
and will help the world come together
for justice for freedom for peace to
sonntag thank you
[Applause]
the to know that Zeus
presently with a multinational oil
company by erisa see Matamata
by Pajero yeah hawawa and then dynast my
dancer hats from the slum delicious
bye
[Applause]
[Music]
try
[Applause]
[Music]
we are coming to the end of the rebel
Peace Prize ceremony here in the City
Hall for Astra as every year the royal
family will now congratulate the christ
winners king hydral Queen Sonja Crown
Prince to Ho : crown prince's little
merit
they're always here for this ceremony
every year
the king and queen then have met the
three recipients earlier today at a
meeting of the royal palace tour today
is far from over for the prize winners
tonight is the traditional labelled
banquet and before that the guests will
watch their also traditional torch light
precision through the Main Street in
Oslo and now the thing recipients of the
phase prize are leaving the whole fold
accompanied by in the very material
religion of equity enter standing
applause from the beasts in the hall
table
[Applause]
and now we also hear the clucks were the
bells so they're the 49 belts of the
power of the City Hall
this year I can mirror leader seungho's
a thousand on this rider from batons
night sinful
[Applause]
and so the Precision's have left behind
and the other guests are leaving the
auspice city hall after Peace Prize
ceremony of 2012
[Applause]
[Music]
you